bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on
discute des sujets qui font l actualité
en 2021 29 % des parents renoncent à
faire des cadeaux à leurs enfants la
raison leur situation économique et avec
ce raisonnement 21% des français pense
aussi qu'ils passeront les fêtes de noël
seuls des chiffres marqueur de précarité
qui pousse certaines personnes à se
mobiliser alors quelles actions pour
faire de noël un moment solidaire on en
parle avec nos invités en plateau
séverine blémant pardon bonsoir bonsoir
si vous êtes responsables des maisons de
quartier théodore monod et auguste
renoir à guyancourt et en visio pascal
rejet bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire général du secours populaire
des yvelines et jean-christophe marais
bonsoir bonjour vous êtes président doit
2002 france des petits frères des
pauvres parce qu'elle voyait j'ai
commencé avec vous que ce que je disais
dans les petites 29 % des parents
renoncerait à faire un des cadeaux à
leurs enfants ça paraît énorme
bah oui mais malheureusement la balle à
la précarité et la pauvreté ne sont pas
des phénomènes nouveaux et avec la
situation un peu dramatique du coc vie
de les situations deviennent de plus en
plus aiguë
rien que sur le département des yvelines
constate aussi un accroissement des
personnes en hôtel et donc effectivement
pour ben plein de nos concitoyens offrir
un jouet un petit cadeau à noël pour ses
enfants ses deux c'est devenu un
inaccessible
depuis 1976 secours populaire à son
assez père noël ce qui aide le père noël
heureux je vous hais les verts c'est un
moyen de redonner du sourire aux
bénéficiaires
nous les peintres n'a cueilli en fait
cherche toujours à préserver leur
dignité donc
on sait qu'au moment des fêtes la
pauvreté la précarité le sentiment
d'exclusion cd des choses qui ressortent
de manière encore un petit peu plus
aigus donc on en met tous les moyens
possibles humain et fraternel pour
alléger ce ces mauvaises sensations que
peuvent peuvent ressentir les personnes
donc ça passe par ma part proposé une
sortie ça passe par proposer des cadeaux
des jouets neufs pour respecter la
dignité des personnes
ça passe car et lutter contre
l'isolément des personnes âgées en
organisant au réveillon le 31 décembre 2
avec les bateaux parisiens voilà on
déploie des trésors d'énergie y compris
maintenant avec un soldat rébus on
peut aider un petit peu plus
efficacement les personnes qui sont en
hôtel et après midi encore on aurait une
équipe de bénévoles qui a distribué des
jouets tous neufs à des enfants qui
habitent en hôtel certains de simples
six jours
des mineurs non des mineurs non
accompagnés
un des situations très difficiles et
pour les parents
c'est beaucoup d'émotions ici qu'en fait
ça contribue à préserver leur dignité
quoi vous savez enfin je sais pas si on
peut se rendre compte
on est ce que ça peut représenter pour
un parent de se sentir
impuissant
surtout que c'est une période un peu sur
consternation donc pour les gens qui ont
rien c'est encore un petit peu plus
pénible à vivre
elsa christophe marais du côté des
petits frères des pauvres bien sûr on
est aussi très mobilisés peut-être plus
en période de fêtes vous aussi
alors exactement or no 1 8 équipes des
désirs in organise des repas comme tous
les ans donc le 24 le 24 août 25
décembre donc il y aura il y aura à peu
près sur les îles in 150 personnes âgées
qui vont être invités à des repas
malheureusement l'étude geither
d'annuler certains repas d'équipé parce
que les les équipes avaient réservé des
salles communales et les communes donc
avec la progression du nouveau virus au
ont souhaité annuler ses réservations
donc il a fallu il a fallu se réinventer
part par la distribution et le partage
de colis repas à domicile donc tuera il
y aura à peu près 450 que les repas
qu'ils vont être qu'ils vont être
distribués est partagé entre bénévoles
et personnes accompagnées d'idées
c'était c'était de se dire que malgré
toutes ces contraintes et et ses
changements permanents de 2 voilà deux
organisations avec l'évolution sanitaire
il fallait qu'on n'oublie aucune
personne âgée qui était accompagné dans
le 78 dans le 78 on accompagne à peu
près 450
450 personnes âgées
voilà et il ya il ya 350 bénévoles qui
errent qui oeuvrent justement à lutter
contre l'isolément de ces personnes aux
aînés font partie des personnes les plus
touchées par les allemands ça doit être
renforcée imagine avec la crise
sanitaire donc noël a peut-être un goût
particulier depuis deux ans alors noël
noël en effet est un moment fort pour
les petits frères des pauvres et c'est
vrai que c'est un aujourd'hui avec des
personnes âgées qui nous appelait encore
maintenant la rwashi bénévoles sur
l'équipe de montreuil dans le 93 mais
j'accompagne personnellement trois
personnages et même qui m'a appelé qui
nous a dit
j'espère que c'est maintenu pour le 24
surtout faut pas nous oublier voilà donc
on a vraiment une détresse là dessus et
c'est vrai que à force d'en parler tout
ça ça crée beaucoup de stress a encore
encore plus de stress et les gens
veulent veulent vraiment se réunir alors
bon on est tous conscients qu'on pourra
pas faire d des grands repas 50 60 mais
voilà l'idée de se réinventer en faisant
des repas à 10 12 5 8 enfin peu importe
j'irai voilà chez les bénévoles chez les
personnes accompagnées dans des
restaurants dans des temps des sommes
mises à disposition mais voilà faute ou
en débatte d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il ya
des équipes qui vont intervenir en ehpad
le 25 pour faire des goûters et puis des
animations autour noël
alors la solidarité est affaire de tous
pour tous ceux qui souhaitent se
mobiliser pour la deuxième année
guyancourt a sollicité les administrés
pour créer des colis solidaire c'est
vraiment qu'est ce qui a amené à
participer à cette opération
eh bien écoutez tout d'abord la
solidarité est une valeur chère à la
ville de guyancourt et ça s'est traduit
justement par la participation des
maisons de quartier et des centres
sociaux à l'opération colis solidaire
qui a été mise en place par le secours
populaire
il faut savoir que nous aussi
effectivement les maisons de quartier on
a ce rôle en fait de lutter contre l'
isolement le collègue en parlais tout à
l'heure
du coude et qu'en fait on a eu
on a su en fait que cette opération
était mise en place cette année en tout
cas les maisons de quartier ont tenu à
s'y associer puisque l'année dernière
malheureusement les équipements étaient
fermés seuls les centres sociaux
pouvaient maintenir un accueil voilà
seuls les centres sociaux pouvaient
maintenir un accueil donc cette année on
s'est dit ça y est on est ouvert on
participe ça donne de l'ampleur à
l'action et on mobilise plus de plus de
personnes et l'aiguillon courtois ont
répondu présent ils ont répondu présent
et c'était effectivement une
satisfaction ça se lisait sur le visage
des des gens qui venaient qui apportait
à leurs colis j'ai des exemples
marquants à la maison de quartier renoir
au sol il ya une habitante qui a
mobilisé toute sa résidence et qui a
ramené 40 kcal et
voilà avila roi il ya une habitant paris
qui a ramené à elle seule 10 colis elle
a décoré elle a pris le soin avec son
fils de décorer les boîtes à la manière
des cadeaux pour nos fera nouvelle
pareille une entreprise donc c'est
peut-être tant au niveau des
particuliers que des meurtriers à tous
ceux qui font le territoire de saint de
guyancourt exactement et du coup pareil
à une entreprise qui a joué le jeu et
qui a ramené 10 colis les gens se sont
mobilisés donc voilà mais c'est le colis
solidaire c'est une opération qui
organisait que le secours populaire
également des yvelines pascal rodier
j'imagine qu'un soutien comme ça des
habitants du département c'est important
et c'est rassurant peut-être
donc tout ça nous conforte dans l'idée
que les français seront sont solidaires
il suffit de leur demander en fait on
oublie souvent
que les gens
sont des êtres humains qui sont doués de
raison mais aussi de sensibilité et donc
lorsque les initiatives sont bien
construites et bien fait
il n'y a pas vraiment de difficultés
pour que les personnes se mobilisent
leurs serra qui a une forte valeur
symbolique est une tradition aussi de
générosité qui il existe au moment des
fêtes donc c'est vrai que tout ça
finalement se combinent bien et c'est
cette opération des colis de noël
solidaire en fait c'est venu des réseaux
sociaux et nous on
on s'est inscrits dedans on est quand
même qu'il fallait
reporter a conçu ce qu'on mettait dans
les colis qu'il fallait que ça respecte
la dignité des personnes et donc ce soit
de ce soit 9 et que ça ça corresponde un
petit peu on veut qu'ils sont exprimés
au niveau 2 au niveau des contenus et la
règle générale on n'a pas de réelles
difficultés les gens jouent vraiment le
jeu et donc voilà où tout le monde s'y
retrouve c'est rediffusé ont commis dans
des villes voisines pour éviter que
certaines personnes retrouvent des colis
qu'elle aurait pu faire et le même pas
ce que je vaux pas s'imaginer que les
personnes visées on va dire ou qui
participent à ces initiatives la les
colis solidaire ça permet aussi un
chacun y compris quelqu'un qui n'est pas
très fortunés de participer et ça aussi
on est attaché si on fait pas de
distinction entre les citoyens en
fonction des revenus il ya plein de
personnes qui roulent pas forcément sur
l'or comme on dit familièrement qui
participent régulièrement à nos actions
et ça on est très attaché et c est aussi
un temps une mobilisation des des
enfants et donc pour notre mouvement
dans flanquant perdu un set une manière
aussi de ba de faire ses premiers pas
pour certains dans la solidarité tout à
l'heure j'ai évoqué mode solo darilus on
avait deux petits une amie bénévoles qui
nous ont rejoints et puis qui mettaient
en sachet les bons ballons et les
chocolats pour remettre aux autres
enfants de l'hôtel et pour nous ce sont
plus que des symboles et des gestes qui
qui permettent de construire une
personne est espérée de faire en sorte
que balla solidarité s'asseoir
nous on est attaché à ce que le monstre
est vide a ri té
concrétisait s'incarnant qu
on ne mettait pas n'importe quoi il y
avait une liste presque inexistante de
quoi est-ce qu'il a fallu aussi
expliquer un peu le concept avant ou
tout de suite séduit les goûts viande
lait guyancourt toit ont compris le
concept est ce qu'il fallait mettre
dedans c'était c'est un vêtement chaud
un produit d'hygiène traitement ils ont
compris nous on communique énormément
aussi avec toute toute personne qui
franchit le pas de la maison de quartier
d'ailleurs justement c'est notre rôle on
en profite en profite de toutes les
actions et donc on a aussi des
affichages qui expliquait effectivement
ce qu'il fallait mettre mais je pense
que les gens ont compris ils ont tous
joué le jeu est effectivement
de proposer des choses neuves en tout
cas alors mettre une petite pierre à
l'édifice tout en jouant et en s'amusant
pour la bonne cause c'était aussi le
credo de la section loisirs du club de
handball de saint cyr fontenay après une
édition annulé en 2020 le tournoi de
noël solidaire était à nouveau organisé
une journée de rencontre pour collecter
des dons leur tournoi a eu lieu le 12
décembre dernier regarder même si les
tenues ne sont pas là pour le prouver
les matchs sont on ne peut plus sérieux
six équipes 5 yvelinois s'affrontent
durant une journée pour la bonne cause
c'est un choix qu'on a fait dès le
départ dès la première édition on a
voulu pas juste faire un tournoi entre
nous mais qui soit aussi pour une bonne
cause et donc chaque année on change de
l'association et a pris le meilleur
déguisement et un prix du meilleur fair
play et puis il ya des animations le
millier aussi qui donne lieu à des
récompenses et là aussi c'est une
occasion de récupérer un des fonds que
l'on que l'on reverra aussi à
l'association après une édition 2010 est
annulée à cause de la crise sanitaire
les organisateurs ont tenu à retrouver
ce moment solidaire avec pour thème
cette année les stations de métro pour
inspirer les déguisements vous avez vu
qu'on a sorti les tenues adéquates parce
que donc notre thème c'était alésia on
n'a plus beaucoup de loi mais par contre
on a plein de romain on vient pour jouer
on vient pour jouer la gagne même si
c'est tournoi loisir on joue quand même
la gagne et puis bah ya eu toujours une
super ambiance donc c'est pour ça qu'on
revient tous les ans toujours eu envie
de rencontrer les nouvelles équipes il a
envie de jouer avec d'autres personnes
l'adrénaline et va pas de moitié s'il
est choisi il ya toujours un peu de
compétition après le plus important
délit mesdames ans et de prendre du
plaisir pour qu'ils arrivent pour cette
dixième édition le club sans syrien a
récolté 540 euros ils ont été remis à
l'association un maillot pour la vie qui
s'engagent à redonner sourire et espoir
aux enfants malades autour des valeurs
du sport
jean christophe marre et on l'entend
depuis le début de cette émission la
solidarité c'est pour tout le monde
qu'on soit bénéficiaire aussi ou
donateurs bénévoles investis est-ce que
c'est aussi aux petits frères des
pauvres vous avez dû modifier vos
activités pour se réfréner en fonction
des envies et des nouvelles
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
certains habitants en france
oui oui on s'adapte on s'adapte en
permanence et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les les personnages et ont des rondes et
souhaité qu'ils ont évolué par rapport à
il ya dix quinze vingt ans les séjours
vacances par exemple avant il ya une
vingtaine d'années c'était un petit peu
une grande colonie à un fait depuis
maintenant on s'adapte de plus en plus
aux souhaits des personnes voilà on a
dit vite on individualise de plus en
plus
les des demandes et des besoins de
chaque personne qu'on l'accompagnent il
ya un besoin de connaître aussi de voir
du monde mais de par les imagine pas ce
qu'on est vraiment dans une époque
téléphone visio comme vous le voilà pour
il ya un besoin d'un contact humain est
maintenant
plus c'est
les petits frères des pauvres sorti le
barrage est le paramètre du bénévolat et
dans le 78 par exemple c'est 5000
personnages et qui se déclarent au mort
sociale c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas de
visites d'amis et pas de visites de
famille voilà donc c'est pas rien il ya
cinquante mille seniors depuis de 75 ans
qui vivent seules donc dans les yvelines
donc les les chiffres sont
les chips on parle parlent d'eux-mêmes
quoi il ya il ya vraiment beaucoup à
faire pour les personnes âgées encore
c'est vraiment ce qu'il a fait lui aussi
réfréner l'aiguillon courtois il ya
peut-être beaucoup d'idées qui se sont
lancés après ces colis solidaire
d'autres envies de solidarité
effectivement les gluants pour toi sont
toujours partants pour le moment il n'y
en a pas forcément eu mais c'est vrai
que voilà on est à l'écouté dès qu'il ya
des bonnes idées qu'on peut mettre en
place en tout cas on est partant aussi
ça peut être aussi l'occasion dans ces
moments là que vous même d'identifier
des personnes qui n'avaient pas été
identifiées peut-être par le ccas les
services sociaux de la ville tout à fait
monsieur rodez disais c'est pas les plus
fortunés qui vont nécessairement donner
certains qui ont un petit peu de moyens
veulent partager ça vous permet aussi de
vous ça vous met la puce à l'oreille
parfois certains oui parce que nous
effectivement dans les maisons de
quartier on assure le d'observateurs
social effectivement donc c'est aussi un
moment où on peut observer on détecte
effectivement des gens qui
exactement pascal rodier j'imagine aussi
qu'au secours populaire vous avez vu la
population peut être changé du côté des
bénéficiaires
ben en fait
surtout on a vu beaucoup plus de monde
arrivé et c'est sa touche toutes les
générations
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'années
qu'on on dit qu'on revoit
des seniors on dit maintenant quand des
personnes âgées avant disait des anciens
ont des vieux dans les permanences
d'accueil du secours populaire j'ai
envie de dire qu'il ya une trentaine
d'années il n'avait vous percevez - st
on voyait moins de personnes âgées
isolées qui poussait la porte du secours
et depuis quelques temps ça se
multiplient effectivement les retraites
bat les retraites ne vont augmenter pas
aussi vite que le coût de la vie les
trajectoires de vie sont souvent hanche
et
on est maintenant avec des personnes ont
dépassé les 65 et 70 ce qui bat ont eu
des parcours professionnels qui ont pu
être un petit peu perturbé et divorce
etc qui appauvrissent aussi les
personnes quand elles se retrouvent
seuls et donc on a concertaient nos
villes on a donc on atteint les 15% de
personnes qu'en plus de 65 ans
et alors il ya un autre élément que vous
veniez par rapport aux personnes âgées
c'est qu'on a aussi des gens qui luttent
contre les romains en faisant du
bénévolat et on a dans nos dans nos
publics bénévoles des gens qui sont en
situation de précarité qui ont largement
dépassé
la limite d'âge entre guillemets pour
travailler mes amis qui ne sont très
très active au niveau des néo vol et le
jeu où je tenais juste à préciser le
bénévolat c'est klaus qui le maintien
d'un lien social et parfois on peut
sauver une vie c'est à dire que ce que
disait monsieur marais sur les gens qui
se déclarant mort sociale je peux vous
assurer que les bénévoles du secours
populaire qui ont plus de 70 ans sont
très vivants
socialement c'est très très très très
denses et donc voilà
les étudiants on a beaucoup parlé et
c'est là que ça fait plusieurs plusieurs
années aussi qu'on dit que la précarité
étudiante c'est une réalité 3 de plus en
plus les lieux d'accueil comme le
secours populaire alors il ya des
initiatives qui sont prises par des
associations étudiantes pour essayer
d'organiser en commun de solidarité
d'étudiants un étudiant donc c'est des
choses qui comptent à respecter aussi
que cette façon on n'est pas dans une
logique de concurrence un plus au ras
des gens solidaires et le mieux ce point
mais voilà on a aussi des artisans des
personnes qui ont perdu leur activité
qui avaient lancé leur réactivité en
auto entrepreneur le coc guide a un
petit peu fracassé de ça donc bah j'ai
envie de dire que tous les profils on
vienne et le problème c'est qu'ils
viennent de plus en plus nombreux et on
a aussi un accroissement assez
significatif du nombre de personnes en
en centres d'hébergement en centre
d'hébergement de réinsertion sociale ou
centres d'hébergement d'urgence aux
migrants aux migrants mais on a de plus
en plus de gens en hôtel pour qui il
faut essayer de trouver des solutions
voilà donc on est un peu occupé et je
vous l'écris termine avec vous jean
christophe marie là quelque chose dont
on n'a pas parlé aux petits frères des
pauvres c'est un kit de chasseurs de
solitude
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
alors le kit de chez third solitude oui
c'est un c'est un outil qui a été mis en
place de manière à ce que les gens qui
veulent pas forcément rentrer en tant
que bénévole dans une association puisse
quand même aidé des personnages et
donc des voisins des d'aider des gens de
leur quartier donc c'est un petit kit
qui peuvent télécharger sur le site des
petits frères des pauvres et donc c'est
tout un outil d'accompagnement de venir
à ce que ce que ce que ce nouveau pas
bénévole mais voilà ce nouveau citoyen
puisse puisse être plus à l'aise sur
l'accompagnement d'une personne qui se
trouvait isolé près de chez elle
ben je vous propose que nous arrêtions
sur ces mots c'est la fin de ce titre
société merci à vous trois d'avoir le
plonger à notre invitation et nos
téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve en janvier pour un nouveau
numéro pour échanger et discuter d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et bien sûr
passer de très belles fêtes sur tv 78
[Musique]